INTRO:
Nowadays, the main reason most people know
Mark Cuban is because of Shark Tank and the
Mavericks.
He’s famous for making offers with short
lifespans and pouncing on entrepreneurs whenever
he feels that something is off.
His bombastic personality and bloated ego
are also hard to miss.
Despite these quirks though, Mark is by far
the most reliable Shark on the show following
through with 87.5% of the deals that he makes
on air.
That’s nearly double all the other sharks,
but when you consider that he’s worth 5
times more than the rest of the regular sharks
combined at $5.93 billion, it’s not surprising
that he’s able to be much more lenient with
his deals.
While Mark often talks about how he had to
hustle to make it to the top, it’s never
made clear how exactly he made his money.
So here’s how Mark Cuban became the only
regular billionaire on Shark Tank.
YOUNG ENTREPRENEUR:
Taking a look back, Mark was born on July
31, 1958 in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania to a
Jewish immigrant family.
His father’s side were immigrants from Russia
and his paternal grandfather had changed the
family name from Chabenisky to Cuban when
he arrived at Ellis Island.
Meanwhile, his mother’s side were immigrants
from Romania.
In the US, Mark’s father was making a living
as an automobile upholsterer while his mother
was a homemaker.
Mark’s family wasn’t particularly wealthy,
but from a very young age, Mark was always
trying his best to make money in any way he
could.
When he was 12, for instance, he sold garbage
bags door to door until he could afford some
expensive basketball shoes.
Similarly, when he was 16, the Pittsburgh
Post-Gazette went on strike, and Mark leveraged
this opportunity to sell newspapers from Cleveland
to Pittsburgh.
Clearly, Mark was doing pretty well for himself
as a teenager, but he had no interest in just
sticking around at the same level.
He would grind through high school and graduate
a year early which allowed him to enroll in
the University of Pittsburgh.
Originally, Mark chose this college because
he was a big fan of the Pittsburgh Steelers,
but after just one year, he decided that it
was much better to choose a college based
on finances.
So, he would transfer over to Indiana University
in Bloomington because it offered the cheapest
tuition out of the top 10 business schools.
Mark never ditched his entrepreneurial side
though; in college, he helped run a pub and
taught disco lessons.
But soon enough, his college days would come
to an end in 1981 when he graduated with a
bachelors in business administration specializing
in management.
Following college, Mark would move back to
Pennsylvania and secure a job at Mellon bank.
At the time, Mellon bank was in the process
of switching from paper to computers, and
this really showcased to Mark the potential
of computers.
But, Mark didn’t stick around for long though,
just one year later, Mark decided to move
to Dallas, Texas and picked up jobs as a bartender
and a salesman at a company called Your Business
Software.
Even today, Mark says that if he had to start
over from scratch, being a salesman during
the day and a bartender during the night is
exactly what he would do.
This way, he would have a stable income from
bartending and a scalable income from selling.
Unfortunately for Mark though, he would get
fired from his sales job during his first
year because one day, he was meeting with
a client instead of opening up the store.
Instead of looking for another job though,
Mark decided that it was time to start his
first company.
MICROSOLUTIONS:
Mark’s first company was a software consulting
service called MicroSolutions.
The business was basically a copy of Mark’s
former employer Your Business Software, but
Mark felt that he could do it way better than
them, and that’s really all you need.
One of Mark’s core business principles is
that execution is way more important than
the idea.
He says that everyone has a great idea, but
very few people are able to execute.
Mark also preaches that following your passion
is one of the great lies of life.
If he had followed his passion, he says that
he would’ve ended up as a failed basketball
or baseball player.
Instead, Mark has always insisted on following
opportunity, and the opportunity with MicroSolutions
was that Mark had already built up a client
base at his old job.
So, he just had to convince them to switchover,
and being the hustler that he is, this wasn’t
too difficult.
Aside from building up a solid client base
including people like Ross Perot, Mark was
quick to adopt new technologies such as remote
screen sharing, client-server software platforms,
and of course the internet.
By 1990, MicroSolutions had grown to $30 million
in revenue and this stellar performance started
to attract some acquisition offers.
And that same year, Mark would sell MicroSolutions
to CompuServe for $6 million which worked
out to about $2 million after taxes for Mark.
Adjusting for inflation, we’re talking about
around $4.2 million which is nowhere close
to being a billionaire, but Mark was more
than happy with this amount.
You see, Mark was never trying to become a
billionaire, he just wanted to be financially
free and enjoy life.
And $4.2 million was more than enough to do
just that.
One of Mark’s first orders of business after
cashing out was spending $600,000 on an American
Airlines unlimited pass.
As the name suggests, this allowed Mark to
travel on American Airlines first class unlimited
times.
Mark says that over the next 5 years, he used
the pass to travel the world and party like
a madman.
Apparently, the long term cost of the ticket
came out to just 12 cents per mile.
To put that in perspective, the average airfare
costs roughly 11.5 cents per mile, so about
the same amount, but Mark was flying in first
class.
This was clearly a terrible business decision
by American Airlines and that’s probably
why they discontinued the pass, but the pass
is still valid for people who already bought
it.
And today, Mark is 1 of 25 people who still
have the pass.
Mark clearly had a blast globe trotting through
the early 1990s, but it didn’t take him
long to jump into yet another business.
BROADCAST.COM
Mark didn’t found this next company; in
fact, he wasn’t even looking to get involved
in another business.
But when the opportunity popped up, he couldn’t
refuse.
One of his friends from college, Todd Wagner,
introduced Mark to a man named Cameron Jaeb.
Cameron had started a company called Cameron
Audio Networks in 1989 specialized in streaming
out of town sports games.
Originally, Cameron was attempting to sell
handheld satellite devices to broadcast the
sports games, but in the early 1990s, he switched
over to streaming over the internet.
Being a massive basketball fan, Mark was super
interested in the idea and he would agree
to invest $10,000 in return for 2% of the
company which valued the business at $500,000.
This was actually a rather high valuation
for the business given that they hadn’t
even launched yet.
Cameron was still working on negotiating streaming
rights with broadcasters, but despite the
early nature of the business, Mark became
increasingly interested with time, and he
would actually offer to take over the company.
Cameron agreed presumably because he didn’t
expect the company to grow that fast or that
big, but this would turn out to be a massive
mistake for Cameron.
Mark rebranded the company as AudioNet and
launched the service in September of 1995.
He would eventually change the name again
to Broadcast.com in 1998.
In the meantime, the business was growing
pretty nicely as they were able to accumulate
570,000 users within the first few years.
Ideally, this business should’ve been worth
a couple million dollars, maybe ten million
at max, but this was during the height of
the dotcom bubble.
When Mark took the company public in 1998,
the stock soared 250% on the first day of
trading which valued the company at $1 billion.
Having a 30% stake in the company, Mark’s
net worth jumped to $300 million.
Later on in 1999, Mark would diversify the
company into video streaming as well helping
Victoria’s Secret live stream a fashion
show.
That same year, Yahoo would offer to purchase
the company for $5.7 billion, and to Mark,
taking the deal was a no brainer as it would
net him roughly $1 billion.
Today, this acquisition is regarded as one
of the worst acquisitions of all time as Yahoo
would end up shutting down the service in
2002.
Honestly though, I think the failure of the
business was mostly Yahoo’s fault.
I mean just take a look at how big streaming
is today.
We have YouTube, Twitch, Netflix, Hulu, Prime
Video, and so much more.
Netflix itself is worth $250 billion today,
so I think Yahoo threw away a massive opportunity
with Broadcast.com.
The same could be said about Mark as well.
Instead of selling the company, he could’ve
tried to navigate the company through the
dotcom crash, and if he was successful in
growing it into something like YouTube, he’d
be worth tens of billions today.
But, Mark preferred to just take the $1 billion
upfront, and you can’t really blame him
for that.
Anyway, after the acquisition, Mark dumped
all of his Yahoo stock within a year which
was really smart given what was coming.
And with that Mark was officially a billionaire
not only on paper but in cash.
GETTING LUCKY:
Mark is actually super transparent about getting
extremely lucky with Broadcast.com.
First of all, he was super lucky to get introduced
to Cameron, then he was super lucky that Cameron
agreed to let Mark takeover the company, and
finally, he got super lucky that Yahoo offered
to purchase the money losing company for billions.
Mark says that if he started over, getting
to millions and tens of millions would be
no problem, but in terms of reaching a billion,
he’d have to get lucky again.
Anyway, after the sale, Mark began to splurge
his newfound wealth.
In October of 1999, he purchased a Gulfstream
jet for $40 million over the internet which
won him a world record for making the largest
single e-commerce transaction.
Shortly after, Mark bought the Dallas Mavericks
for $285 million in January of 2000.
Mark wasn’t really trying to make an investment
with the team.
He really just loved basketball and wanted
to help grow a team to the top, but this has
ironically turned into a fantastic investment
thanks to the team’s stellar performance.
Before Mark bought the Mavericks, they only
won 40% of their games, but in the ten years
following his purchase, the Mavericks won
69% of their games and they even won the NBA
finals in 2011.
Today, the Mavericks are valued at $2.7 billion
which is nearly a 10x on Mark’s investment.
Mark has also been trying to get into the
show business for quite some time, and though
Shark Tank is extremely successful today,
the same cannot be said about Mark’s initial
endeavors.
One of Mark’s first attempts at starting
a TV show was in 2004 when he produced a show
called The Benefactor.
The show was kind of like the Apprentice.
16 contestants would compete in various challenges
to try to win $1 million, and Mark would judge
their performance throughout the show.
But unfortunately, ratings were so bad that
the series was canceled before the first season
was fully aired.
Around the same time, Mark also bought Magnolia
Pictures and Landmark cinema, and though these
have been good investments, they’re nothing
spectacular.
Something spectacular was just around the
corner though.
SHARK TANK:
Mark first appeared as a guest shark in 2011,
and it didn’t take long for him to become
a regular shark.
Ratings for the show have ballooned ever since
he joined the team, and he’s one of the
most sought after sharks by entrepreneurs.
Within the first 10 seasons of Shark Tank,
Mark made over 100 deals on air, and given
that he has the highest closing rate, we can
assume that most of these went through.
In terms of money invested, as of 2015, Mark
had invested a total of $19.85 million on
air, and this figure is probably closer to
$40 million today which is the highest on
the show.
In terms of percent of net worth invested
though, Mark is the lowest as he hasn’t
even invested 1% of his net worth because
he’s just too big of a baller.
Anyway, Mark has a reputation for making short
life span offers and he loves to hate on supplement
companies, but at the end of the day, Mark
always has the entrepreneurs’ backs.
Originally, Shark Tank entrepreneurs were
forced to either give the production company
2 percent of their profits or 5% equity in
the company if they wanted to appear on the
show.
Honestly, this is a pretty fair deal given
that sales usually explode after a Shark Tank
airing, but Mark felt that the production
company was already making more than enough
money and that they didn’t need to eat into
entrepreneurs’ businesses.
So, he threatened to leave the show if the
company didn’t drop the Shark Tank tax,
and given how important Mark is to the show,
the company agreed.
And that’s how Mark Cuban went from a teenage
boy selling garbage bags to being everyone’s
favorite billionaire on Shark Tank.
Do you guys think Mark just got lucky with
Broadcast.com?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you wish that you were
as lucky as Mark.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.